non-minimalists
how do we determine which apps to delete
you kind of talked about this earlier
with the seasonality rule
there's a lot of different rules you can
apply here i think yeah for me it's yeah
i
i get to a point every once in a while
where i get overwhelmed by my apps now
i literally have like on my home screen
there's nothing the only thing i have on
my home screen is the kindle like that's
a thing i can go right to and read and
like uh so that's the only thing that's
like right there available everything
else i have four different folders
and i have four different folders and
all the apps go in one of those four
folders
and uh yeah even then like as clean as
it is i still start to get anxious
sometimes it's usually there's a
utilities folder and that's kind of like
my catch-all like if it doesn't fit in
the other three it's a utility yeah so
uh yeah long story short when i get that
overwhelming feeling when i start to
recognize it as clutter
that's when i'm like okay i have to
think about the boundaries i've set up
and start deleting some some uh some
apps you can start with that deleting
ten percent of them today if that if you
need some momentum another thing you can
do is so you talked about some of the
boundaries some of the rules that we
have we talked about the seasonality
rule
the just in case rule if you're holding
on to any of those just in case
then let go of those apps immediately
always re-download them yes
yeah and and guess what once they're out
of the way
the thing about the justin case rule is
you almost never go back to those things
you're holding on to just in case the
just for win rule so i'll give you a
couple examples on that we have like i
have not flown on an alaska flight in
the last 90 days and i don't think i'll
be doing it in the next 90 days although
with tour it may happen
um and so
if
i i know i'm going to use alaska at some
point again yeah and so i just expand
the seasonality rule for me sure to be
one year one year on something like that
and then there's the emergency item rule
which applies less to apps but maybe
there's some sort of emergency app that
you're going to need have access to i
don't maybe there's an app you hope you
never have to use but it's there in case
you need it that's what emerges
emergency items are the just in case
items that you hope you never have to
use right that's the best way to look at
emergency items yeah and then another
rule the spontaneous combustion rule
which we've talked about but if that if
that app just deleted from your phone
automatically
would you feel relieved or would you
re-download it yeah and if so then if
you feel relieved that's a sign to go
ahead and delete it it's so easy to
declutter these apps you just have to
spend some time i do this with my photos
as well we're gonna talk about photos in
a bit but if you have some trigger to
declutter your apps maybe just the first
day of the month or maybe it's like
anytime i'm at the doctor's office or
i'm waiting in line somewhere i'm going
to take that time to remove some of
these apps from my phone and finally if
you want to get really really aggressive
with it what if you did the 30-day
minimalism game but with apps
so you start the first day of the month
you get rid of one app second day of the
month two apps so forth and so on
and if you make it to the end of the
month you would have gotten rid of about
500 apps yes which i guess maybe some
people have that many abs oh wow play
that with a friend or a family member
and that's um
that's where i'm going to start did you
enjoy this video if so you can listen to
full episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free